[Music]
shannon's in boise idaho hi shannon how
are you
i'm very good thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
well i have a question about short-term
life and insurance my husband and i have
short-term life insurance
but we have about half as much as you
recommend
and um
i guess my question is is why do you
recommend so much okay good question
well we call it term insurance not
short-term insurance and we recommend 10
to 12 times your income and so you're
saying you got about five times your
income
and and we recommend we recommend 15 to
20-year level
term insurance so what's your husband
make
he makes about 250 000 a year wow
awesome yeah well you may not need to do
that it's up to you here's where the
idea comes from
okay if we want to replace his income
and and the investment upon his death is
going to make ten percent
that means you need ten times so if we
had ten ten times two and two hundred
fifty thousand that'd be two and a half
million dollars right
two and a half million dollars invested
at 10 creates
250 000 a year income
okay so we're trying to replace his
income now in euros case there's two
possibilities that might mean you would
want less
one possibility is you don't need 250
000 to live on if he dies
right okay so you would you could reduce
it to
10 times whatever you want to live on
okay okay the other possibility is he's
making bank right now and you guys ought
to be investing in building up your
investments and the more you have in
investments
the less you need insurance
right if you had two and a half million
dollars in in in mutual funds right now
and he died you'd be okay you wouldn't
need life insurance at all
okay because you became self-insured so
as your assets increase your debts
decrease
and
if you want to live on less than his
current income ten times whatever amount
you're gonna need that his
that your investments won't create
so if you already had like a million
dollars in there and you wanted to add a
million and a half to it then you just
need a million and a half you know you
wouldn't need that so that but that's
where the calculation comes from it's a
fairly primitive
basic calculation but it gets you pretty
close most people don't buy enough life
insurance because they buy the wrong
kind they buy expensive whole life rip
off cash value rip off flexible premium
adjustable universal double backflip
insurance crap
you know and then and it costs 10 times
20 times more than it should so don't
buy enough
so that's the thing
that's the point we're after here so um
just get enough that your family can
be okay
off of the investment returns
if he dies
that's what the concept is we're
replacing his income or replacing your
income if you die too by the way
this is the dave ramsey show